the battle for Winterfell has been
confirmed by a bunch of leaked photos
during past few months for the final
season the production has made for the
very first time an actual battlements
and outer walls that were in previous
seasons added in with CGI HP also laid
down white tarps all over the place in
preparation for fake snow if there was
not going to be any battle scene filmed
in the winter fall said the production
would not have to bother with building
actual walls with which main characters
and extras interacted with neither would
they have to have fake snow settlements
real people were going to march over it
basically they've overhauled the set
this year building physical battlements
and towers that used to be added in with
CGI in my previous videos I explained
this was done in preparation for a big
battle scenes as you don't build
physical structures so unless you plan
to have actors interact on them long
story short I said Jon Snow and almost
the entire living side will face hundred
thousand strong army of the Dead in
front of interval and it's now been
officially confirmed there are photos in
which we can see two hundred-plus armed
extras fighting in huge battle some of
those men are the unsullied building
spear tipped with dragonglass meaning
they are clearly fighting against the
army of the Dead even though at first
glance it might look more of a flame of
Daenerys dragons it's actually flame of
Azarian the night Kings Dragoon is
burning down Winterfell at some point of
the final season yes his flame burns
blue but they color the flames in
post-production Winterfell is the
ancestral home oh how stark and also
where the whole game of Thrones sexual
began with a little finger effectively
triggering the war of the five kings
within its very grounds season seven
left of it Winterfell being ruled by
sense alongside her siblings sari and
bran it's also the location where Dana
John and Jamie and pretty much every
main character is heading at the end of
the last season leaving a big
possibility that some of them might die
in this huge battle for Winterfell while
some of you could argue with me saying
it might be Yura in the golden company
that are attacking Winterfell
rather the denied king once earned the
assess receipt of how stark will fall in
the final season